there was a sketch where you played
David Crosby on Saturday night yeah they
had a uh I just saw the sketch recently
I know it was uh it was a Christmas
I don't know like a rehab Christmas
celebration show and Phil was Johnny
Cash and Nora was Liza Minnelli and I
was David Crosby and we're like you know
it's Christmas and I just played him
like he's completely out of it and he's
still like high as a kite like what
ground you know and a few years later
this is really funny he got an award
from music cares which is a the charity
arm of the Grammys and he gets an award
for like being sober for a year and
David calls me goes John I want you to
get up at this thing it's like a
thousand people it's a sit-down dinner
and I want you to like come out as me
the way you did me on the show and
totally out of like I go when I was
totally out of it and now he goes yeah
yeah I want you to do it and come out
and accept the award as me so I come out
I think even and I go anyway it's really
good Ram anyway so I'm playing it like
just out of my skull like I don't know
what's going on out of it and afterward
everyone's like that was so
disrespectful respectful how could you
do that he just won an award for being
sober and you're up there
like he's out of his gourd so I went up
to David after and I go hey I'm really
sorry I didn't mean to offend you he
goes no no no no I I no one is laughing
goes no no John I loved it he goes I was
crying laughing and everybody at my
table is laughing their heads up I loved
and I go okay good as long as you liked
it he goes no no I loved it you know but
everyone else in her room was like oh my
God I can't believe this guy but you
know what's so great about that story
it's exactly why I love David Crosby
like here he's getting this serious
award for sobriety and and like and his
first thought is oh I can't take this
seriously I gotta ask John Lovitz to go
up and play me and you know I mean the
guy's so [__] so [__] awesome that
he would even ask you to do that it
shows such a sense of humor because I
thought the story was going I played
David Crosby and then I met him and he
was like trying to kill me because
um I was making fun of him but they guy
the guy didn't have a thin skin you know
it's just great